how are you doing today
good how are you
i'm doing excellent i want to start with
how uh
how
i don't know what i just [ __ ] up my
already my beginning i was going to say
how great you did in the movie um
i really uh i thought the movie is so
good and i'm sure you're hearing that
from everyone you're talking with um i
think for fans though of the material
they might be surprised that your
character is a lot more fleshed out in
the movie than uh on the stage can you
sort of talk about that aspect of it
yeah sure um that aspect of it makes me
very nervous uh because
alana is a bit different but hopefully
it just feels to people like there's
more time for us to learn who she is
um
but you know i'm well aware of the fact
that
it's the original play is so incredible
and there's so many incredible actresses
who have played ilana and yeah i hope i
hope hope
that people who are fans of it resonate
with this version of alana
but she
is a girl who is kind of
overcompensating with her over
achievement um
because she
has a lot of complicated parts of
herself
that she's figuring out just like evan
and just like everyone at that age
and she also is dealing with depression
and anxiety and it's something that she
connects with evan around and something
that
motivates her
to create the connor project
uh i thought
the anonymous ones which you co-wrote is
such a good song can you sort of talk
about working on the lyrics and um being
able to add something to this uh to this
move yeah sure
um
i mean yeah i still can't even believe
that that benj and justin invited me
into the process of
writing with them like
they're legendary humans and so to even
trust me or be interested in
collaborating with me like blew my mind
from the jump i'm so grateful
um
we
kind of started with images and moments
and something that
that i kind of got fixated on was this
idea of
what happens when someone's mask kind of
cracks for a second and you maybe see
like what's actually going on with them
or you see that there's something deeper
there
and especially now when like we've all
kind of
we all kind of do this compulsory mask
maintaining especially with like social
media and everything um that felt like
uh maybe the most meaningful thing for
me to explore also because it's kind of
my full-time job to like have a mask on
so
so i so i think maybe i needed a little
i needed it a little bit too um and
so we
kind of started with that idea and
explored it further and thought like
what would happen if we all kind of took
these masks off and were vulnerable and
talked about what we were actually going
through or talked about the fact that
we're not perfect or we do have
depression and anxiety or we are dealing
with these things
what would the power be in that um
and
hopefully the power is that it makes
people feel less alone when they watch
the movie
yeah i think the song is fantastic and
uh i'm already out of time i'm just
gonna say again congrats on the movie
you guys did such a great job
thank you appreciate it cool have a
great day yeah